By the age of 24 Hermann Garing
was a famous combat pilots,
a national hero and leader of Germany's
most celebrated fighter squadron.
By the time of his death,
less than 30 years later,
he was reviled as a monster with
the blood of millions on his hands,
highly decorated combat pilot, drug
addicted, lunatic international statesmen,
and one of the 20th century's
most notorious criminals.
Garren's life was one of
soaring highs and crashing lows.
And in the biographics video this
week we explore the life of this man.
The young Hermann Goering
enjoyed a privileged upbringing.
His own mother and father had missile
money, but his Jewish Godfather,
Dr. Herman Epstein, was fabulously
wealthy and he welcomes the gehrings.
Do you live at one of his two castles?
This appearance acts of altruism was
no doubt influenced by the facts that
Epstein was having an
affair with gehrings mother.
If her mother was aware of this,
then he didn't seem to mind.
The two became close with
Epstein Encouraging Hammon
and his love of hunting,
climbing, and adventure. When
Goering develops an interest
in all things military.
It was again his Jewish godfather who
pulled some strings to have the boy in
roles at the prestigious military
academy had calls row in 1914 the great
European powers when to war Garing was
by then 21 years old and serving in an
infantry regimens sensing that would
be better opportunities for glory.
Elsewhere.
He applied to join the imperial German
flying call and began his new career as
an observer, but when the opportunity
arose, do you get behind the controls?
He seized it with both hands.
He proved to be a natural flyer.
It's thanks to the countless
hours he'd spent hunting.
He was already a lethal marksman.
This was a deadly combination
for an aspiring combat pilot.
By October, 1915 bearing was newly
qualified and hungry for glory.
He only had to wait a little over a month
before he scored his first kill them.
By June,
1916 is Tali had risen to three a few
professions in history I've ever been
quite as dangerous as a world
war one pilot since in November,
1960 and he was shot down
for the first and only time.
Accounts of the incidents are
sketchy and contradictory,
but there's no doubt of that.
Gehring did suffer an injury that kept
him out of action for several months on
rezoning to DOTC begins or rack up kills.
It's an impressive rate.
He rose through the ranks of aces winning
numerous awards for bravery and just
fame began to grow.
His face was printed on
collectible matchboxes
newspapers and magazines featured
articles on him. Everywhere
he went, people treated him
like a celebrity Gehring.
He adored the attention.
In April 19 the Germans suffered a major
blow when their greatest pilot man read
Ron Rec. Seven better known to history as
the red baron was shot down and killed.
Race often had been commander of an elite
squadron made up of Germany's find a
stamina.
It was assumed that his replacement would
be drawn from their and the likes of
earnest Udit and Luther von Rick.
Seven the red baron's brother were
considered the most likely candidates,
but as it turned out, he was actually
Hermann Goering who landed the job.
This game is something
of a surprise guttering.
He hasn't been part of the rector,
often squadron,
and he was still some way off the top
of the charts in terms of Kilz. However,
Garren had skill, he had charm, and
he seemed to be a natural leader.
Gehring took charge of the rich
often squadron, a difficult time.
The balance of power in the ad swung
back and forth through the war,
but now the allies were
firmly in the ascendancy.
German aircraft production couldn't
keep up with the British and French
factories,
attrition and exhaustion where taking
their toll on German pilots as well.
The situation on the grounds,
it was equally desperate.
Shortly before gehrings promotion,
the United States of America
had declared war on Germany.
A huge offensive designed to knock France
out of the war before American troops
arrived in any great numbers fails.
Germany suit for peace and the armistice
came into a, on the 11th of November,
1918 gehrings lost orders were to lead
his squadron to a French Sheffield with
Iraq.
Croft would be handed over to the allies
in a tearful final speech to his men.
He predicted our time will come again.
Gatherings,
exploits made him a household name,
but he missed the excitement
that the war had provided.
Recruiting for other pilots from amongst
his wartime comrade see put on a series
of highly dangerous acrobatic shows,
dazzling thousands of onlookers with
his daring stunt flying when the public
began to lose their appetite for this
sort of spectacle called took on a more
modest job flying charter planes.
It was during this time that he met the
love of his life counters. Karen Vaughn.
Farc was sickly and frail
and already married,
but she was also wealthy and beautiful.
The guttering, it was love at first sight.
Karen,
she felt the same way about the dashing
m and and in 1922 she abandoned her
husband's and a child to make a
new life with Gehring in Munich.
It was here that the couple
of first encountered adults.
Hitler at this point in history hit
though is still something of a non entity
rabble rousing demagogue with missile
real power influence Karen. However,
she was in trust and she was determined
to form an alliance between Gehring and
this Austrian corporal Gehring willingly
bounties face to that of ad off Hitler
ends in November of 1923 he joined
his Mazda and a plot to overthrow the
government.
2000 Nazis with Hitler and Goering side
by side and the front rank marched on
the Bavarian war ministry hitting the
believed the police would not oppose them,
but you underestimated their resolve.
They opened fire and hit the foul or by
some accounts fledge while gathering was
badly wounded by a bullet to his thigh.
Hitler and his conspirators,
they went now wanted criminals and this
was a particularly difficult situation
for Gehring since he was one of the most
recognizable faces in all of Germany.
While Hillary was arrested,
Gehring chose to flee having received
treatment from ironically enough,
a Jewish doxa Gehring and carrying
across the Austrian border.
The next two years would be the
most miserable of gehrings life.
Gehrings wound became badly,
in fact, done in Austria.
He was given injections of
morphine to ease the pain.
This was the beginning of an addiction
that would almost cost Gehring his sanity
and even his life, the ones athletic
ace pilots way you said balloons,
Karen and sold most of her possessions
to fund gehrings habits and just wild
mood swings after fearing for her life,
faced with the very real possibility of
losing Karen airing agreed to enter into
a withdrawal or a program
during the great war,
the first battle of gehrings life,
he had fought for his country for
personal glory and for Prestige is second
grade struggle against morphine.
Addiction had none of that glamour.
It was a feisty,
very night he lost.
He screamed at his nurse is that they
wanted to meet death and even attempted to
physically attack them for his own safety
and the safety of everyone around him.
He was forced into a straight jacket
and confined to a padded cell to Karen's
relief. Gehring emerged from the
depths of his own personal highlands.
He was discharged from the asylum
in October of 1925 less than a year
afterwards.
The German government grounds at him
an amnesty absolving him of his crimes.
He was free to or a townhome and to
resume his service to add I'll Hitler who
would been himself released
after just nine months in prison,
having failed to gain
control of Germany by force,
Hitler instead attempted to seize
power through the ballot box.
In order to accomplish this,
he needed a wealthy back is to embrace
the nationalist socialist because Hitler
was a brilliant public speaker,
capable of whipping crowds into a frenzy,
but in more intimate social settings,
he was awkward and uncomfortable.
Most of the other senior Nazis
were unsophisticated thugs. Only.
Garing was entirely at home wining and
dining German society's elites gathering
that threw himself into his new role.
We've huge energy and commitments,
but his beloved Karen's health was
by now seriously deteriorating.
In October of 1931 she collapsed
and died leaving Gehring distraught.
He would later condition the building of
a huge country residence sets in 40,000
hectares of woodlands.
Naming it.
Karen hold in a memory in January of
1933 had succeeded in maneuvering himself
into the position of
Chancellor of Germany.
Gehrings reward for his years of service
was to be appointed Prussian Minister
of the interior through his ministerial
salary, corruption and bribes.
He founds the means to fund the lifestyle
that was becoming opulent to the point
of absurdity to go along with his mansions
is exotic pets centers increasingly
ostentatious. The uniforms Gehring.
He also held real political power.
His first step was to
not certify the police,
sacking 22 police chiefs
and replacing them with men,
sympathetic national socialism with the
police loyalty or should he ordered them
to crush subversive elements in society,
which in practice meant
Jews and communists.
Gehring made no attempt to distance
himself from these killings.
He stages every bullet fired from the
barrels of a police pistol is my bullet.
If you call that murder
than I am a murderer.
Everything has been ordered by me.
The biggest threat to Hitler, however,
did not come from the communists but
from within the Nazi party itself,
the folks of the essay,
but Nazi parties own para military.
Army had been useful to hit
her when his rise to power,
but they'd become a bit of a problem.
Hitler wanted the essay to be broken up,
but its commander and rom openly
defied him. The men of the essay,
they were loyal to Ron.
If he attempted an armed cue,
he might just succeed in toppling hip
goring who hated Rahman's recognized a
very real threat to his own power.
He urged his fury at act and reluctantly
hypno agreed on June the 30th 1934 the
night of the long knives began. It was
time for Hitler to settle some old scores.
Now on Strom was arrested.
I'm shot dozens of those.
You had angered or obstructed
Hitler in one way or the other.
Much of the planning had been entrusted
to Guerin who executed the operation
with great skill and they
complete lack of moral scruples.
Headless position within the
party is now become unassailable,
but he was already looking forward to
the day when he could attack Germany's
neighbors and a venture to feet and
the Great Wall Germany was banned from
building an air falls under the
tons of the treaty of Versailles.
So Garing was tossed with
building a top in secret.
The Germans had been preparing for the
day when the air force would rise once
again since long before the
days of Hitler coming to power.
While Germans were barred from developing
military aircraft to the band on
civilian aircraft had been
lifted in 1922 since then,
the German aviation industry has produced
numerous fast mail carrying planes
that could easily be converted into
fighters and airline is that could be
converted into Obama's Lufthansa.
Germany's state owned airline,
which was formed in 1926 would provide
many of the pilots for gehrings fledgling
Luftwaffe that showers
with lavish funding.
Gehrings fledgling Luftwaffen grew quickly
and in March of 1935 it's existence
was officially announced to the world.
Over the next four years.
The Luftwaffe out red receive four times
as much investment as Britain's RF and
it's more than 10 times that,
uh, France is our force.
Unlike the allied air forces,
it was designed specifically to operate
in support of Germany's ground forces.
The World Class Messerschmidt one oh
nine became operational in 1937 and it
forms the backbone of the
Luftwaffe as fighter force.
The drunk is Jua 87 stock,
a dive bomber rammed machine for which
neither the British nor the friendship
and he'd direct equivalents which provide
support of a Germany's fast moving
armored spearheads.
It's guttering later adult is captures.
In 1945 we arms Germany until we bristled.
Guttering didn't entirely share
Hitler's his enthusiasm for war.
And this wasn't due to any sense of
compassion for the millions who would die,
but simply because handsy much to lose
his time was spent mixing with high
society,
indulging his passions for hunting and
collecting art and expanding his own
personal empire within the Reich.
Unlike Hitler,
he didn't see himself as being on some
sort of quasi divine mission to restore
German greatness.
He simply pursued a political career
because it brought him personal power and
enormous wealth. We're Hitler
thought victory was inevitable.
Gathering you it wasn't fair.
He might find himself on the losing side.
Just slide the reservations
of many of his generals.
Hitler chose war and on
the 1st of September, 1939,
Germany invaded Poland. The Luftwaffe, uh,
was at this time the most
powerful air force in the world.
It's commander in chief,
however,
was largely untested as a military
commander in World War One.
He had spent a few months in
command of a single squadron,
but that was a very different matter to
directing operations of an entire air
force in a very modern war.
While Gehring possessed the intelligence
and ruthlessness of a great military
commander,
he would fail miserably in the role.
This was at least in part because the
corpulence Gary had too much on his plate.
In addition to being the
Luftwaffe as commander in chief,
he was also responsible for civilian and
military aviation policy, the Reich's,
anti aircraft defenses, industrial
and economic policy, and a good deal.
More than that. These responsibilities
were far too much for any one man,
particularly one who was once
again sliding into drug addiction.
In 1937, Gehring had been prescribed
the pain killer park or Dan,
they morphine derivative to
treat a severe too thick.
The tooth ache eventually went away,
but Gehring kept on taking the drugs.
As the war turned against Germany,
Gehring continued to up his dosage.
His drug use compounded his weaknesses
as a military leader is continual
overestimation of the
Luftwaffe as capabilities,
there's tendency to retreat from reality
rather than face up to bad news and a
desire to please Hitler,
which repeatedly led to him making
promises the Luftwaffe it could not keep
sometimes with catastrophic results.
Gehrings fading capabilities were not
immediately apparent in the attack on
Poland's, the Luftwaffe, uh,
made short work of the Polish air
force and it's obsolete machines.
In 1940 it was Frances done
and the Luftwaffe are once
again dominated the skies
as German tanks emerge from
the supposedly impossible,
our den forest threatening to in circle
the best of the French and British
divisions as the British prepared to
evacuate their army from the continent.
The German army had spear heads were in
position to sweep into Dunka can deal
what might have been a death blow to
the British expeditionary force going,
however, persuaded had led
that is Luftwaffen could
finish the job on its own.
The German tanks were halted in the
Luftwaffen hit the British with everything
they had the limits of what our power
could and could not achieve had not yet
been established and nobody had ever
attempted to destroy an army from the APP.
If during kind of given the matter
sufficient thoughti might not have been so
confident.
The vast artillery bombardments of world
war one were not enough to win battles
without support and the Luftwaffe couldn't
come close to matching that kind of
hitting power gehrings most spree of
hollow and a huge armada of ships plucked
to the British expeditionary force to
safety across the English Channel with the
British having fled the consonants in
the French signing an armistice on the
22nd of June,
1940 Hitler was bemused ins in rage to
discover the Britain had no intention of
giving up the fight.
He began planning an invasion but
stipulated that it couldn't go ahead until
Britain's Royal Air Force had been
destroyed as an effective fighting force.
Once again, Garing was on hand
to assure Hitler that has lifted.
Martha would make short work of the RAF.
He believed the Luftwaffe to
be superior in every respect,
but this simply wasn't the case.
The British chant,
roughly the same number of finances is
the Luftwaffe are in this super marine
spitfire is every bit as good as the gem
and anyone I nines person also had the
advantage of radar and just
sophisticated ground control system.
And thanks to gehrings and ability to
get the most out of the German economy.
British factories were producing more
fighter aircraft per month than the entire
Reich. Gehring also believed himself to
be on the brink of victory throughout the
battle of Britain best. He never
came as close to the sea imagined.
Gehrings third big mistake.
If the ball runs,
almost certainly his most calamitous
came in the wake of Hitler's ill judged
invasion of the Soviet Union.
When the sick Thalami became
in circles at Stalingrad.
It's the only hope was to attempt an
immediate breakout hit the hated of the
idea of retreat under any circumstances.
So when Gehring claims the traps on me,
you could be supplied from the, uh,
the Fiera seized upon the suggestion.
The idea was total nonsense.
Scaring staff knew it,
and I Geiringer really should
have known it to their results.
Who was the complete destruction of the
sick Thalami and starting grads became
the turning points of Welsh water here.
So at this point,
and Hitler no longer trusted Gehring
and the Luftwaffe achieves reputation.
It plunged new lows as the allied
bombing campaign systematically destroyed
German cities.
Garrin now to be as best to stay out of
Hitler's way rather than a tends to as
many responsibilities.
He spent the bulk of his time hunting.
There's Karen whole plundering Europe,
the avast you add to his enormous
collection and consuming ever greater
quantities of drugs.
On April the 30th 1945 Hitler committed
suicide with the right collapsing all
around him. Gehring knew that the war
was lost. Unlike most other top Nazis,
he either killed themselves
or attempted to flee.
Gehring seem to be under the bizarre
impression that he hadn't done much wrong
and therefore have less.
It was a fear.
On May the ninth he surrendered himself
to the Americans along with 20,000
painkillers and one of the
world's largest art collections.
Most of it looted from all across Europe.
Gehring had expected an audience
with Eisenhower. Instead,
he was accused of crimes against
humanity and waging wars of aggression.
His guilt or innocence,
these charges would be decided at trial.
While the prosecution propent that case,
scarring was weaned off his drug
addiction and placed on a strict diet.
The results was that the much diminished
Gehring who has blended his way through
the wall was now restored to the cunning
manipulative force of old of the 21
leading Nazis on trial at Nuremberg.
Garing was the most senior.
He didn't expect to
escape the death penalty,
but he did intend to go down fighting.
In one of the exchange,
he rang so many rings
around the prosecutor,
this the American threw down his
headphones and refuse to continue with the
cross examination.
Gehrings argument was that he hadn't
wanted war and did work to avoid it when
forced to fight through
circumstances outside of his control,
he had done so with the principles
of a noble to tonic night.
It was not in his nature to harm women,
our children,
and he had no nothing of the Holocaust.
Given his powers of self delusion,
he may well have convinced
himself that this was true.
Whatever the case he was enjoying being
center stage again at least until he was
presented with evidence that shattered
this image of himself as a noble warrior.
The idea that Gehring could have no,
nothing of the Holocaust was absurd,
but there was this little documentary
evidence linking directly to it. However,
there were plenty of documents indicating
that he had participated in the
persecution of Jews and personality
profited from it. Not only that,
but tens of thousands of slave laborers
had toiled and died in the Luftwaffe as
factories and under Gary's leadership and
look to ofa had conducted horrific and
often lethal experiments on Jews,
Gypsies,
and prisoners of war and funds
in Europe for works of art,
ordered prisoners to be shortened,
had allied m and lynched.
The judge found gathering guilty on
all charges and pass down a sentence of
death by hanging Gehring objected.
He was a soldier.
Rents as soon as she should be executed
by firing squad rather than hanged like
a common criminal.
When his demand was refused,
Gehring took matters into his own hands.
On October the 15th he bit
down on a cyanide capsule.
Quite our Gehring obtains this cyanide
capsule is still not known for sure.
His suicide note explained that he felt
no obligation to submit to his enemies
justice while awaiting trial.
He had told psychologists that within 50
years there would be a statue of him in
every German in town.
Gehrings opinion of himself had
not been dented at all by defeat,
but his judgements of his place in
history, certainly well wide of the mark,
his exploits as a brave fighter, pilots
have been utterly eclipsed by his crimes.
Few men have a trashed their reputation
quite so comprehensively as Herman
Gehring. So I really hope you found
that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos
like this three times a week,
so hit that subscribe button and you
will learn all about those when they come
out,
especially if you hit the bell because
the subscribe button doesn't do what it
used to. And as always,
thank you for watching.